(audience applauds and cheers)
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- Wow!
- I don't get-
You look great!
- Thank you.
- Oh, thank you.
Well, I was told I was pre-diabetic,
- Were you really?
- But that's literally,
like, what happened, they were like,
and I was like, well, I wasn't shocked.
- Yeah.
- I was a tiny bit overweight, so, yeah.
But I wasn't shocked by it,
but they did, they were like,
"You're pre-diabetic, you're
right on the borderline."
I was like, "But I'm not there yet."
- [Kevin] Yeah, exactly.
You got some room to play.
- And then I waited two years,
and then did, however,
- Oh, it was getting closer.
move into the-
Yeah, I was like,
- Yes, we're getting close.
- Okay, I'll do something
about it.
- Yeah.
- No, but that photo,
the meme was seen everywhere,
that we showed in 2023.
- So Stupid.
- Did you know that,
that it went around? (laughs)
- I had no idea, my kids showed me.
Like, I didn't know what was going on.
It was ridiculous,
but I was happy people
were thinking of me.
That's all.
- You have, literally,
there are so many memes of it.
Do you have a favorite that you've seen?
- There were a couple that
made me laugh really hard.
There was one with like, I had a bowl cut,
and I don't remember what it said,
but it just made me laugh.
I had all the chains around my neck.
- Well, you had a bowl cut,
so right there.
- Yeah.
It just, it got me.
But there were tons of them.
They just, and it didn't stop,
- Yeah.
- You know?
- It's funny.
- It was ridiculous.
- We need to laugh.
- Yeah, we do.
- Yes.
- And it was the goofiest shot ever.
- And speaking of that,
is there ever gonna be a
reboot of "King of Queens?"
People are doing reboots,
I'm just saying.
- Are they?
Yeah.
- I'm just saying.
- I don't think we can, man, because-
- Without, yeah.
- Yeah, we had Jerry,
Jerry Stiller was so
- Yeah.
- A part of that show,
I would
- Yeah.
- Not want to do it without him.
- Yeah, it's such a huge show
- He just, he's amazing.
- In pop culture, I think people
are just like, ugh,
- Yeah.
- Nostalgic.
- I love him.
- Yeah.
- Oh, I miss him.
He's amazing.
- Yeah.
- It's amazing to work with a great cast
that you click with like that.
- The best.
- Yeah.
- They were the greatest.
Leah's incredible and-
- Yeah.
Love Leah, yeah.
- Yeah,
so it was so much fun to do,
and such a great time in my life,
and it was like, you know,
I get to see it still, it's on,
so people, you know,
- Yeah.
- Still come up to me now.
Younger generations.
- Well that's thing
with streaming,
now people are seeing
it for the first time,
and it's like, well, this is older,
but yes.
- Yeah.
- It's brand new for you,
- It's weird.
- I guess, yeah.
- Yeah.
I had hair.
- I mean (laughs)
- Yeah.
- I know, but you actually
look pretty badass.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah, like, I was gonna,
- Thank you.
- I was thinking that
when you walked out, I was like,
no, this is it, this is a look,
this is a vibe.
- It is?
Okay.
- Yeah.
- It's gotta be,
- God made it that way.
- Yeah.
No, you grew up here,
and I just moved here,
and I love it, by the way.
- Do you love it?
- I love it.
I didn't know if I would or not.
- Right.
- I was very worried,
but I love it.
- Well, yes,
it's gotta be a big move
for you, right?
- Big move, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And I'm Texan at heart,
- Yes.
- Like, a out-in-the-country
kinda person,
- Yeah.
- So it was very different for me.
But what are, like, some places to eat at?
'Cause I try and go
- Oh,
my goodness.
- Every week somewhere.
- Well, Long Island,
for me, I'm on Long Island,
and the pizza there
- Yeah.
- Is absolutely insane.
- Pizza is our family's favorite.
- Okay, yeah,
so there's a bunch of places
you gotta check out there.
There's Little Vincent's
in Lake Ronkonkoma.
- Okay.
- That is unbelievable.
They got meatball heroes.
I know everything, this is so sad.
That I know all this.
- No.
- La Scala's, that's another one.
There's Branchinelli's Pizzeria.
- Okay.
- L&B Spumoni Gardens in Brooklyn.
- Someone write this down.
- Yes.
You know that one.
- I was like, yeah.
- That's incredible.
You gotta go there.
- Okay.
- And when you get it all
together and you do that,
and by the way,
I'm not against going to all of them.
If you want to, you know.
- Yeah.
- Tour de pizza, yeah.
- Yes.
But you have to top it off with a malted
at the Farmacy in Brooklyn.
The Farmacy in Brooklyn, with an F.
- Yes.
- Is pretty insane.
Do you like malteds?
I dunno if people like malteds.
- I love a malt.
I don't even bother with a shake.
- Thank you.
By the way, I got them for you.
- Oh, you did? (gasps)
- Yes.
I wanted, yeah.
- I love it.
- This is pretty sick.
- Okay!
- Look at that.
Thank you, Sal.
- Oh my God.
- I'm gonna be honest with you,
I have never had a vanilla malt.
- [Kevin] You've never had a vanilla malt?
- I've only had a chocolate.
- I've only had vanilla.
- Look at these worlds
- That's the way I am,
- Colliding.
- Very boring, and-
(audience laughs)
So here-
- Oh my god.
- This is,
how good is that?
- I love a malt.
- I'm gonna be in trouble,
because we're shooting a
documentary on me getting in shape.
I have to really-
- [Kelly] Oh.
- I'm not kidding.
I wish I was joking.
- Yeah.
- My trainer's-
- I often tell people,
'cause they're like,
"Oh my god, Kelly Clarkson's in shape."
No, there's a very big difference
between being in shape,
- Yeah.
- And losing weight.
- A hundred percent.
- I am the latter. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- I am not in shape, yeah.
- You look great.
Well, you're very nice.
- This is fantastic.
- This should help.
Thank you, Brooklyn Farmacy.
This is incredible,
I've never had a vanilla one!
- I can't even focus on what
you're talking about right now.
I gotta-
(audience laughs)
- It's so good.
I am lactose intolerant though, so.
- Wow.
- I'm gonna just, yeah,
I'm gonna set this aside.
- That could help the bit.
- So we all get through the day.
- Yeah, just a little bit.
Oh, wow!
- Yeah.
- Oh, wow.
Sorry, we're talking, what's up?
We are back with Kevin James
give it up, please!
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Sorry, we were just
talking, so whatever.
His new comedy special is
called, "Irregardless,"
it's on Prime Video.
So why title it that, why, "Irregardless?"
- "Irregardless" was, by the way,
I think it's a word now.
I think it's in the dictionary now.
- I questioned
if it was a word, yeah.
- But people would correct me
and say, "The word is regardless."
And I didn't know.
I just would still, I'd throw out,
like, I do that with a lot of words.
I just kinda make up words
and kinda force 'em into situations.
- I like it.
- Whenever I panic,
and like I, you know,
- Yeah.
- I think I know what I'm talking about,
so I'll throw out a word.
- Yeah.
- And irregardless was one.
And I got scolded on it a couple times,
and I just fought it, I was
like, "No, you're wrong."
(audience laughs)
And now I'm right,
'cause I think it's in the dictionary now.
- Yeah, there you go, Webster agreed.
- Yeah.
So do you, I hear that
you're pretty physical
with your comedy.
Have you ever gone too far?
Have you ever gotten hurt
or hurt someone else?
- Not in stand-up so much.
I did pull a hamstring doing, like,
a little came out dancing,
and I did pull a hamstring,
and the rest of the show
was kinda on a stool,
but other than that,
pretty safe in stand-up.
- You know what's funny,
is like, the older I get,
it's like, I'll just be like, walking,
- Right.
- And pull something.
- Oh my god.
- And I'm like, what?
And they're like, "Oh, what's the story?"
I'm like, "No story, just
getting old, I guess."
Like, I don't know what that is.
Like-
- Reaching for corn,
I popped a rib in the back, you know,
I literally was like-
- Put on my seatbelt,
something tweaked my back.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, are you serious?
- Yep.
- Like-
- It happened for me,
it's age,
- Yeah.
- I don't know what it is,
but it's like, I gotta
keep moving, otherwise-
- Also out of shape, for me,
but yeah.
- Me too.
- We sound like old people.
- I know.
- Okay, so wait. (laughs)
So wait, your tour is
called, "Owls Don't Walk?"
- Oh, the new, "Owls Don't Walk," yeah.
- Yes, I'm pretty sure they do.
But where did this come from?
- Because I didn't know.
- Oh.
- 'Cause I was playing golf
in Atlanta, and I was with
a bunch of my buddies,
and I hit a tee shot, and
it was a horrible one.
It went across, like, two fairways
and it like, rolled up against the woods,
and they were laughing at me,
and I grabbed my 5-iron
and took my cart over,
'cause I had to go punch out of the woods.
And as I get closer to it,
I see there's a dog
sitting next to my ball.
And I thought that was weird
that they let dogs on
the course in Atlanta.
And as I walked closer, I realized,
"Oh, that's not a dog, that's an owl."
It was an owl sitting
right next to my ball.
So I thought like, "Oh, this
little guy must be hurt."
And I started walking towards him
and he went like, (growls)
he did like, a move.
He got like, wide, and then,
he was not afraid of me,
and he just started walking towards me
and it freaked me out.
I was like, "I got a 5-iron here."
(audience laughs)
And he looked at me like,
'That's not enough club."
- That's not- (laughs)
- Yeah.
- And you're gonna need a bigger boat.
- And I literally got into
a foot race with an owl
on a golf course in Atlanta.
So it was pretty embarrassing.
So that's what I thought
of, you know, for the-
- I really wish there was footage of that.
- Oh god.
- Like,
just the owl coming at
you and you being like,
"Wait, what?"
- My buddies wish there was, I know that,
because they were,
I was really panicked.
- [Kelly] Scream like little girl.
- I didn't know what an owl could do.
I don't know what, you know.
- I love owls.
- You do?
- Did you grow up near them?
- And how I know they're-
Not really, but I just,
I own a ranch in Montana,
and they're big there.
- Exactly.
- And they land,
and they, right in front of
where I put trail cams up,
and that's how I know they walk around.
'Cause they walk around
- Yeah, I didn't know-
and try to get stuff in the snow.
- Yeah, I had no idea.
But I always thought owls-
- They're huge,
They're wingspan are, they're massive.
- I just thought they were
intelligent, you know?
They got the little graduation
cap and the glasses.
I thought-
(audience laughs)
- And very exorcist,
- Yeah.
- Like, their heads go 'round.
- Yes, looking around,
the big eyes.
- Yeah.
When their heads go around, it's crazy.
- Oh, it freaked me out.
- Yeah.
- His head didn't move,
and it was freaking me out.
He was just staring at me,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I didn't like it.
I didn't like it.
(Kelly laughs)
- So I hear this about your son,
he's musical, he plays piano.
Right?
- He's crazy good, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
Is anyone in your family
musical like that?
- Well, all my kids are pretty musical.
I wish I was good, I can't-
- Keep him doing it, yeah,
- I will.
I wish I would've done that.
- He loves the classical stuff too!
- That's, ugh.
- And I'm like,
- If you can play classical,
- No, I'm like,
- You can play anything.
- "Get off of that stuff.
You gotta beat Billy Joel's career."
No, but no, that's,
training-wise, like, they
say that with singers,
guitarists, piano, anybody,
like, if you can nail classical,
you can pretty much
float through any genre.
- But where does it go?
What do you do, you're
just playing like this?
- It's beautiful.
- Oh no, no, we gotta make money.
We gotta get out there.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
We gotta...
- Don't do it for the art!
- Yeah.
(Kevin and Kelly laugh)
No, he loves it, so.
- No, that's great.
No, I'm telling you though,
if he can do that, he can do anything.
- Yeah, well that's good.
- Yeah.
- Get into some blues,
yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, all right.
Well we have footage,
actually, so let's hear it.
It's beautiful.
(Kannon plays piano)
(audience cheers and applauds)
Ugh!
I love it!
It must be so cool to
like, enter the room,
and your son's playing piano.
- It's fine, but what do you do with that?
That's all you, this is what you do.
Show it on Kelly Clarkson.
- No!
That's like, a great outlet.
Even if he never goes into music.
- All right.
- Having that as an outlet
is so therapeutic.
- It is, it is.
- He's good.
- Yeah.
- And, again, all my kids are good.
So it's like,
it's pretty cool growing up with them.
- But you have one son,
and is it three daughters?
- Three daughters.
- That's a lot of estrogen.
- Woo!
- Yeah.
(audience chuckles)
- [Kevin] You're not kidding.
- Your boy's gonna be built
for a relationship.
- Yes, yes.
- They're gonna force him to be ready.
- I know.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- It's on, it really is.
- Yeah.
You wrote a song!
You said you weren't musical,
but I heard that you
wrote a song recently.
- I'm not musical, but
I love to think I am,
and I love to get out there and try,
and I partner up with a buddy
of mine, Mike DelGuidice,
who plays for Billy Joel.
- Yeah.
- You know, in his band.
He's just amazing, and, you know,
so I'm always writing songs for him
and having him,
he wrote, you know, a couple songs for me,
and it's just like, we just
go back and forth and play,
and I'll show up at a show.
- See?
But wait, you don't use it
for anything other
purpose than you love it.
You love it.
- That's true.
- See?
- That's a good point.
- Yeah.
- You're right, all right.
- You should listen to yourself.
Okay.
(laughs) You have good ideas.
- Yeah.
- Well, we need another break.
Kevin's special is called, "Irregardless,"
it's a word, people.
It's on Prime Video,
and go online for info on his tour,
"Owls Don't Walk,"
but they do.